as the world continues to acknowledge
the power that anime and manga have on
modern pop culture we've begun to see
the amazing effects of this japanese
inspiration
other countries now create their own
animation series that even rival japan's
in entertainment quality as well as
other platforms and formats becoming not
necessarily a replacement but more so a
rapidly growing accompaniment to manga
and books and light novels for readers
across the world fervently seeking fresh
new content
with full color and a format easily
accessible from your phone or any device
you can mindlessly scroll through
webtoons are hard to ignore for manga
fans looking to expand their horizons
and admittedly i haven't dug my teeth as
far into webtoons as i would like to
aside from solo leveling god of high
school and tower of god my knowledge and
expertise in this area is quite notably
limited
but i will say that despite that i
believe that i can still recognize a
good promising series when it comes
around no matter what the format may be
the makings of a confident strong and
well-written protagonist
excellent world building that makes me
excited for the mystery and long journey
that is to come
and often a neglected trait of series
with powerful main characters a cast of
side characters that still feel fleshed
out and
honestly just relevant
i found all of this and more i believe
in doom breaker
a hot up-and-coming webtoon that has
reeled me in and genuinely engrossed me
in a way that few series do nowadays
zephyr is humanity's last and strongest
soldier we're thrown into the midst of
his lone battle against tartarus the god
of destruction and lord of demons the
one who took away his friends and
everyone he ever loved in the war
against the demons that has left zephyr
as the sole remnant of hope in this
feudal battle for what is now only a
memory of humankind
tartarus whether it be out of respect
for zephyr or as a final attempt to
humiliate him and laugh as he begs for a
chance to live offers humanity's
strongest soldier a chance to join him
and the demons
a chance for humans peak form to ascend
past his feeble frame
and as zephyr reaches out his hand to
the demon god she responds with exactly
what we would hope and expect of the
last human left
shaking tartarus's hand and triggering
his self-destruct spell
zephyr tells him
screw you [ __ ]
in his last moments though zephyr feels
regretful over his inability to avenge
those he lost he actually manages to
humiliate tartarus by injuring him for
the very first time in his eternal reign
as the god of destruction
it's a bitter defeat
and then he awakens
finding himself in the pantheon of the
gods zephyr is informed that at the
insistence of the gods themselves it has
been deemed that zephyr will be sent
back in time as a chance to change how
things ended
to erase this bitter defeat and replace
it hopefully with victory
though he will lose his physical
training mana and acquired skills he
will retain one thing
his memories and all of the knowledge he
has amassed throughout his life as the
most powerful human in the world
but zephyr isn't stupid it's something
you learn quite early on this isn't just
some checkpoint he can restart at some
perfect chance offered by the holy and
benevolent god above
when tartarus began slaughtering
humanity people's prayers to the gods
were ignored their offerings were
refused the priests who borrowed this
divine power originally were stripped of
it
the gods decided that humans no longer
had anything left to give and abandoned
them
so what reason could they have for
sending zephyr back in time
we want to see something
a little more entertaining
they enjoyed watching zephyr struggle
for years against the demons and were
saddened to see him die so soon they
even gave him a little help before he
died to try and keep him alive longer
for their entertainment like he was just
a play thing
which of course zephyr does not take
kindly to knowing that the lives of his
loved ones were nothing more than a show
for the god sitting idly by
even tartarus himself requested that
zephyr be sent back in time in order to
erase this humiliation from history's
record a petty act
but one that zephyr is fully ready to
take advantage
of given perks from the gods to support
him on his journey or rather make his
story a bit more fun in their eyes and
with the knowledge he's amassed zephyr
gladly takes up the chance to rewrite
history and take vengeance upon tartarus
and the other spiteful gods watching his
story
on zephyr's journey we watch what is
basically the epitome of someone
replaying a video game they've already
done a 100 walkthrough on before
having insight on how to quickly gain
power and the quickest methods to level
up on the early stages revealing and
utilizing information on enemies who
zeffer already knows details about half
of his conversations with new enemies
start with how do you know that
after zephyr reveals some piece of
information that no one in the world
would ever know
and while you think this might get old
the part that makes doom breaker great
is more so seeing how zephyr deviates
from what is essentially the original
story
zephyr is on a mission
everything he does has a purpose in the
long run to change the future
and his plans to befriend and meet
certain people from his past life come
with challenges but with his knowledge
of who they are and their stories he's
able to do it
he's essentially preparing humanity and
the people he knows for the danger and
war that lies ahead maybe even prevent
it he might be able to break free of the
doomed fate that lies in store for him
and the rest of humanity
in spite of how cheesy it might get i'm
a sucker for series with really
overpowered main protagonists
they tend to have a lot of problems
don't get me wrong it's something i
generally coin as the opmc dilemma a
poorly explored supporting cast a
shallow main character who fails to show
much growth over the course of the
series
villains who don't get a chance to shine
because they're quickly dismantled by
the protagonist
most series with an obviously
overpowered main character are
susceptible to at least a couple of
these issues
a good example lies with the later
stages of dragon ball z
during the buu arc the series begins to
disregard its side cast giving gohan
goten and trunks
massive power upgrades that were
immediately disregarded and used as
power upgrades for an antagonist whose
only trait was being an adaptive pink
alien who couldn't speak
leaving goku as the sole star of the
show and giving him super saiyan 3 a
power-up that held no emotional or plot
value like super saiyan 1 and super
saiyan 2 did except to simply be strong
to fight majin buu
but many series handle this dilemma
excellently and actually use it to their
advantage
one punch man avoided the issue of a
character who shows no development by
well embracing it
having the most simplistic funny main
character in both name and ability he is
exactly what you call him
mobscycle 100 has full fleshed out arcs
for many of its side characters avoiding
that issue of a weak supporting cast
many of whom have actually become fan
favorites in the series like regan
likewise doombreaker handles the issue
very well
zephyr is physically overpowered but not
grossly so
because he restarts with no skills or
mana except for the abilities given to
him by the gods he does have to continue
getting stronger through the story
he experiences many roadblocks hindering
his abilities early in the series as he
comes to terms with a body that is far
weaker than the one he used to have
but what sets this series apart from
most is that zephyr is insanely
overpowered not so much so in physical
abilities but in his knowledge
the true nature of most of the
characters in the story lets him
manipulate the tale to his will and the
location or method of gaining abilities
gives him the strength he needs to back
it
more than anything being physically
strong is just a way to support his
overarching plans rather than being
zephyr's biggest asset
he's a smart strong and scheming main
protagonist who you can't help but be
entranced by
and if you couldn't tell from the panels
i've been using the art is amazing
there's something utterly addicting
about reading through webtoons i'm not
sure if because of the simple top to
bottom format that it feels so easily
digestible or if the series is simply
that intriguing or both
i caught up with this series and was
genuinely ready to pay on the webtoon
app to read the extra five chapters once
i got there i think that doom breaker is
going to big places and i can't wait for
every single chapter that comes out
weekly
i highly recommend it
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses
you